let's get into it we got the story from
the Washington examiner Joe and Hunter
Biden caught on 17 recordings with
barisma owner Grassley reveals FBI form
or Grassley reveals FBI form says I love
that that would be it should be a
semicolon and not a comma after the word
owner right there yeah so we could
understand the conflict that's
interesting it's not the owner Grassley
is revealing that there is an FBI
informant saying this right and so this
is this is official in Intel in in to
the FBI now being released to the public
a top Senate Republican revealed Monday
that an FBI informant said the Ukrainian
oligarch involved an alleged criminal
bribery scheme with Joe and Hunter Biden
also claimed to have 17 recordings of
his conversations with the president and
his son Grassley revealed on the senate
floor that a largely unredacted version
of the bureau's fd-1023 confidential
human Source form said that the foreign
National who allegedly bribed Joe and
Hunter Biden allegedly has audio
recordings of his conversations with
them 17 such recordings I want to pause
right now and say okay
the bribery thing is really interesting
but what we can't say for sure is that
Joe Biden admitted publicly on camera
that he threatened to illegally withhold
congressionally approved loan guarantees
to Ukraine unless they fired a
prosecutor as we now know that
prosecutor was investigating barisma so
here we are I guess the uh correctly if
I'm wrong uh Jack the bribery was that
they went to Joe and said get the
prosecutor fired well and and to be
clear the investigation was so the guy's
name is Nikola slachevsky and he and so
zlichevsky is the oligarch who is in
control of purisma
um
he was under investigation domestically
in Ukraine and by the way yes the same
Ukraine that has the war that's been on
fire that seems like dominates all of
the conversation over the last six years
when prior to the last six years I don't
even know the last time any of us even
talked about Ukraine right it Trump's
impeachment the War uh the the coup in
2014 suddenly Ukraine is like everywhere
um
he was under investigation for bribery
inside Ukraine then he goes and hires
Joe Biden which we know publicly he goes
and hires Joe Biden's son Joe Biden gets
the prosecutor fired then he said he's
bribing Joe Biden to stop the guy who
was investigating him for bribery in the
first place
okay okay so zachevsky is the is this
post oligarch that's in control of
barisma yes he he's the guy that hired
Hunter Biden yes and then
um and then he bribed Joe Biden to stop
and vet to get to get a prosecutor fire
to stop investigating his company well
so and according to these reports
um it seems as though the hiring of
Hunter Biden coincided with and again
based on the report I I interviewed
Marjorie Taylor green who has seen a
copy of the report she also gave me some
more information stating that This
Confidential human Source this or CHS as
they say in the parlance is uh someone
who was one of their most highly
credible this is this isn't just some
walk-in some random guy like hey I heard
about uh Joe Biden and the uh you know
by the way so there's there's a whole
process and I remember when even when I
was an Intel agent you know or Intel
officer that there's this question of
how do you know that the source knows
well you're constantly vetting placement
and access you're constantly vetting uh
credibility you can go back and check
you know did a person actually go to
this place where they said they work and
you check can you Geo track them et
cetera et cetera so there's a huge
process that the FBI is running on this
person to make sure that the reports
that they're giving are credible which
by the way could also include recordings
of you know wearing a wire right as we
all know from movies Etc so the idea is
that this informant is giving that
report to the FBI and saying that that
this hiring of Hunter which we knew
publicly coincided with not one but two
five million dollar payments one two
Hunter Biden and one two the big guy so
these recordings how many are shell
companies how many of the recordings
were Biden and how many uh how many were
Joe and how many were Hunter two Joe 15
Hunter that makes sense to me because
you know Hunter's the one who's actually
working in barisma he's there right
probably having a lot of Converse
stations check this out they say the
examiner says sources previously told
the Washington examiner that the barisma
owner discussed an alleged bribe of 5
million dollars to Joe Biden and a five
million dollars to Hunter Biden
according to the paid FBI informant who
said he heard this from zlachevski the
sources said he believed it would be
difficult to unravel the alleged bribery
scheme for at least 10 years because of
the number of bank accounts involved
there's clever ways they can run this
they could do something like look
I've got a company in this country that
runs a couple subsidiaries that harvest
wheat
we'll we'll have those companies hire
you as a consultant through your
investment firm so it looks clean and on
the level that's how they play this game
then you get like multiple bank accounts
involved where money's being transferred
all around and then you've got to prove
the transfers were specifically for the
bribe so it's very difficult unless you
have them on on on audio tape talking
about what they're doing and how they're
doing it well also unless you're the FBI
which literally exists to I mean the FBI
has
agents that are specifically tasked with
working with the U.S treasury Department
to actually go after the and unravel
those very same uh shell games that
you're talking about and so what's
what's so shocking to me is that we're
seeing now they're even in the report
Grassley alleges that when they first
went to the FBI and asked to see the
hunter Biden file that there were
portions that were redacted relating to
these audio files that the FBI redacted
that before they gave that report to
Congress wow so the FBI was actually
trying to now they're going to claim
right of course the FBI will say well
that's because of our informant that's
because it came from the informant but
here's the thing
you you don't need to say that in the
report that it came from an informant
you can just say the FBI has information
and the FBI as we know has multiple ways
of receiving information and so they're
redacting that clearly raises a huge red
flag of all sorts of issues not to
mention separation of powers not to
mention the administrative State versus
the the elected representatives and you
really have to go back and say look I
know a lot of people were
let's say I would try to be nice here
skeptical or at least not sure of Kevin
McCarthy the House GOP in general they
said are these guys actually going to do
anything are we actually going to get
information out and I would say look I
mean say what you want about you know
certain certain fights certain Hills to
die on Etc that we would not have this
information right now if the both ends
that right now if the House GOP had not
brought it to us Tim I know you got that
reference
I want to read this this is a very
important paragraph in the story
Trump and his Republican allies claim
Joe Biden improperly used his position
as vice president to pressure Ukraine to
fire shoken to protect his son from an
investigation into bursma Democrats deny
this and argue the focus on barisma was
part of an effort to dirty up Joe Biden
well hold on everything in that
paragraph is true
I don't understand
this is the same keep in mind let me
just just to clarify it so when Trump
and other Republicans investigate Joe
Biden for overt and obvious corruption
it does in fact dirty him up in the
election and I'm sure that played a a
played a role in why they would do it
you mean kind of like but all the
resting your leading opponent right
right you know all they're doing is
they're saying Democrats deny it but
argue a part of why they would do it
which okay look if you are running for
office and you find out that your
opponent is a criminal you would
absolutely be like we must defeat this
person because they're a criminal and we
can't let them run this country so yes a
component of what you're doing is we
need to expose the dirt on Joe Biden
it's real
this is the exact same thing that all
the way back in 2019 and all and if some
of these names maybe not lechevsky but I
think people have probably heard the
name barisma a lot by now and you know
even at a general level these are the
same exact companies and names that came
up in that Infamous perfect phone call
between Trump and Vladimir zielinski
write the same Vladimir zielinski I got
my zielinski shirt on today
um you know I see you guys aren't
rocking brand new guys you're close
you're close but you got you got your
showing the guns off the whole thing
it's like uh but there's this idea that
when Trump was talking to zielinski and
he was asking him hey I've heard about
all of these things I've been watching
the news I've been seeing that Joe Biden
obviously at one point literally bragged
about it on national TV that he got the
guy fired and he's saying look you're in
Ukraine you're the president of Ukraine
could you look into this could you make
a few phone calls could you see what's
going going on they impeached president
Trump for just asking the question about
this right here which we now know keep
in mind Tim that at the time that they
did the impeachment the FBI had all
these reports on file and not a single
one of them came forward and said well
actually what president Trump is talking
about is something that we have on file
there is a there is a criminal Syndicate
in the government
I mean I don't know how many I don't
know you know but we know that the FBI
is purposefully not Prosecuting certain
individuals and so whoever is
instructing these people to do this is
part of some kind of criminal Syndicate
I'm not trying to make it seem like
there's a network of thousands of people
with initiation or anything like that
I'm saying certain elements of the FBI
the executive branch and the Democratic
Party
are absolutely subverting the law in
this country in collusion with each
other end of story there was that you
see that clip out of CNN where the guys
are like Hillary Clinton had the cell
phone smashed with hammers and I think
it was Allison Camerota she's like can
we no no can we get a fact check on that
and the guy goes yes the the Hillary
team did have phones smashed with
hammers and and servers wiped and she's
like oh you mean like with a towel
whoops it is funny when I hear people
say like didn't Hillary Clinton pour
bleach on her computer and it's like oh
geez man like the the bleach bit bleach
bit wasn't it was an app it was a
program to to purge a hard drive which
the guy found on Reddit yeah that was
funny was that what it was he posted
saying like I need help too and they
found his posts on the subreddit because
he's talking about I'm working for a a
very important individual who really
really needs something deleted it's it's
it is crazy to me that Donald Trump is
facing a Federal indictment despite the
fact that Hillary Clinton did
substantially worse exactly for a fact
we know she had classified documents in
her private server that she kept and it
was destroyed and all of those emails
the 30 some plus thousand that we know
of were public records that she
destroyed and nothing happened and she
posted that picture of her hat but her
emails and smiling it's like they broke
the law they got away with it and now
that Trump's getting arrested they want
you to know that they will keep
committing crimes and nothing will be
done that's why I was talking to Jack
before the show and I'm like well what's
the next like what's this long game
going to be are they gonna come out in
the media and be like but you guys Joe
Biden had to get the FI the prosecutor
fired otherwise we wouldn't have had any
protection against Russia when they
invaded Ukraine we all we did all this
manipulation for your own good like
they're just gonna one day just flip the
lights on admit it all and say it was
for your own good and then 90 of the
population will just believe it with
their jaws slack like that's my fear
here well you're you're right you're
actually right about that is that's
always been the Playbook when it comes
to one of these things because the first
thing the first time you say it it's
well that's conspiracy that's not
happening as as Tim pointed out that
some of them are actually getting the uh
getting it wrong and they're still
pulling that out for the the email
server when actually we've gone past
that one so the first thing they do is
they say it's a conspiracy then the next
thing they do is they say it's contested
then the third thing they do is they say
well this helps Republicans and that's
the only reason Republicans are going
after it for it and then finally once
you've completely proven something
beyond the shadow of a doubt they'll say
well okay it is happening but it's good
it's happening and it's happening and
it's good and here's why it's good for
the country and everyone that's why it's
happening and how dare you stand against
us for letting this happening so I don't
know if that's exactly the reason
they'll give but I think you're 100
right and that they will at some point
come out and say you know these payments
were made for the betterment of Ukraine
the security of Ukraine and Hunter Biden
was secretly working on a you know an
exchange program for uh certain forms of
UK Iranian women on a uh on a uh a need
to know and a special special access uh
Visa you know for the really you know
High Talent people will come to me then
I'm trying to to you know Shadow
campaign this myself in a few months
they'll come to me whenever after this
comes out and they'll be like but Ian it
was good that what they did with with
Biden with uh getting the people fired
and I'll be like now I've got to figure
out how to explain to them why it's not
I need to be so laser focused I need to
know Nick Nicholas lachevsky inside and
out Victor shoken inside and out these
names
two guys maybe like 500 times and I tell
you it's like I hear it's like it's
washing over my brain every time Russian
guys uh Ukrainian names uh words like
barisma Victor shoken this zlachevsky
zlachevsky was an oligarch that owned
barisma correct correct fled the country
uh during these investigations met Tybee
reported around a dozen I believe and uh
Biden comes in and gets the prosecutor
fired which was Victor shoken the
problem
signed a sworn affidavit saying that he
was fired because of Joe Biden that the
Ukrainian officials came to him and said
we have no choice Biden said we have to
fire you maybe he swore he swore to this
there's also and and this is coming back
around again that there's audio that was
released by oan years ago
of phone calls between Biden and not
zlichewsky but poroshenko who was the
previous president of Ukraine
petroporoshenko prior to they call him
the chocolate man the Candyman because
he ran a he was a sort of a chocolate
oligarch and he's still around by the
way he's still a member of the um the
parliament there and he's the one who
ran against zelinski in 19. anyway in
those calls at one point poroshenko says
to Biden there is nothing
that we have found that shows that
shoken is corrupt we have no information
that says he's doing anything wrong but
if you want us to do this we will do it
and Biden's pushing him saying we need
to do this and there's a bank and the
kalamoiski's bank needs to be taken care
of et cetera et cetera and what happens
after the prosecutor is fired zlachevski
returns to Ukraine and what happens
after Donald Trump makes the infamous
phone call he flees once again once once
he knows like uh oh uh oh they're gonna
start looking into me again and Joe
Biden was like we got someone in there
who was good
yeah good but then what's the next step
there is who's
what did the oligarchs then do so
kalamoisky is the other oligarch who's
working with lejewski at this point is
has the bank is sort of the financial
end if you look at it that way
um he has got the bank
Biden's saying I know this guy you know
he's kind of an a-hole et cetera et
cetera but we got to deal with him we
got to deal with him that was the bank
that received the IMF money
so those oligarchs come in and say look
we still got this problem with the
presidency et cetera Etc and you know
now Trump's in what do we do so they say
what if we can bankroll our own
president here in Ukraine and
that same oligarch ran a TV network and
on that TV network they had a very
popular TV show called servant of the
people all about a
teacher like a you know public school
teacher who becomes essentially becomes
the president that actor
was named Vladimir zielinski and those
oligarchs then decided to put him up and
bankroll him to become the new president
of Ukraine in 2019. did he have any
political Acumen before
no he was just an actor and they were
like you're good enough I was a comedian
and then an actor and he played the
president on TV and they're like works
right wow let's jump to this next story
is it was the same oligarchs that are
being discussed on this phone call with
Biden thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time